hey gang welcome to the ru garbage
comedy podcast
make sure you subscribe so you get the
videos as they come out
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey everybody
and welcome back to everybody's favorite
new podcast god damn it
this is are you garbage the show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
find out if they grew up classy
or if they're just a big old piece of
[ __ ] i'm your host stage foley coming at
you on a gorgeous
day down here aunt tony's basement she's
upstairs right now
crushing up and snorting her gout
medication
and i gotta tell you not a bad high all
right it's pretty good
i want to give a quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire real quick
switching it up a little bit he is the
uh
he's the magic man okay and for a
limited time right now you can get him
with a cup of coffee and a hash brown
ladies and gentlemen give it the [ __ ] up
for toby
t-bone mcmuffin look at that
dude your [ __ ] mission in life is to
ruin my internet reputation yeah all
you all my dm's are [ __ ] horrific
nicknames buddy
the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
and the t-shirts are gonna be a t-shirt
on top of a mcmuffin i can already see
it
coming with a side of slaw look at him
over there gang it's a [ __ ] family
episode today no company we're circling
the wagons
right now it's just me you the boys the
whole [ __ ] squad we're here together
so let me introduce to you my co-host
extraordinaire
this gentleman drives a late model sedan
and i gotta tell you he looks the part
yeah
just got back from a hot weekend at the
spa uh-huh
out there in kingston pa that hot bed
for [ __ ]
couples relaxation he's a pocono kid
give it up
for our good pal kippy kevin
james ryan hey gang happy to be here
thanks for having me big man i
appreciate it buddy it's just you and me
it's family time right now this is it
huh
yeah big happy loving family you ever
have that where you were supposed to go
over to your friend's house or something
like that and his dad's like you know
nah it's just family tonight
you ever get that do that i think they
just didn't want you rooting through the
pantry if you ask me
don't let that foley bozo come over eats
all the pretzel rocks
this kid goes through the roto uh what's
up everybody
uh thanks for listening please make sure
you review subscribe on itunes
full video available on youtube yes you
know what those numbers are true to
[ __ ] roof but they could be higher
could be higher
[Laughter]
come on gang and then obviously um if
you want bonus content you can sign up
at patreon.com oh yeah garbage you can
get uh bonus episodes at ayg every week
and get episodes of hard feelings which
you've not hold on one second hello hard
feelings we got them you want them to go
hard feelings baby come on sign up
it's it's a it's a look behind the show
it's me and holy [ __ ] on each other we
do a little hr you know what i mean
airing of the grievances
it's a good time people think we're nuts
people are like
somebody just commented last episode
this is the most passive aggressive
episode i've ever heard in my life
we go at each other that's right it's a
struggle for power it's a struggle for
power down here in the basement
yeah um so and we're not like you see on
tv all right we're real people those
numbers are true to roof as well
not bad i got something just came across
the wire i can't believe this you've
asked for it you've wanted it
it's taken us a while to get this i'm
selling please i'm so excited we had to
jump through a couple of hoops there had
to be a couple of payoffs couple
senators had to resign we had to [ __ ]
have to fill up let's go
i had to fill out [ __ ] immigration
customs paperwork for this stuff federal
docks kippy's but what do you got
kippy's got kid's got a full house right
here
show them kippy look at that
toby zoom in on that do some fireworks
do a little
something act now while supplies last
the are you garbage home game
is [ __ ] ready to ship yeah we got
it's uh it's over 50 of uh you know some
of the classics boom first one i pulled
can you guess what it was randomly
uh is this your car uh oh do you drink
milk with dinner good night
guys uh the game is available limited
supplies is our first run of them
um you can go to ru
garbage.bigcartel.com
the link is right here check it out
flashing explosions act now
limited supply yup the ru garbage card
game is out
go to [ __ ] the website and get them
and hook it up yeah give it to a friend
valentine's day is coming up throw to
brood something nice
yeah uh yeah you can play strip all your
garbage see how that works out ooh
that's a [ __ ] great idea we could
play that here in studio that could be a
patreon episode
gotta look at that big old sazich on the
mcmuffin
get the get the mcmuffin on camera baby
let me see the old
toby is that hot or sweet sausage i
don't know but i want to find out the
card game is
card games available check it out
supplies letters i'm telling you now
it's going to sell out this isn't my
[ __ ] you know
this isn't who's the guy that died billy
ray no what's his name billy ray who was
the
famous sales the shamwell got no no not
the championship
it's one of the bad guys and back to the
future um
billy mays billy mays that's right yeah
i'm sure i'm not trying to be billy mays
here but there's a limited supply
and uh once they're there they're gone
we might do some more in the future
obviously but
if you have a leak in your boat slap one
of these babies on there
yeah before the infomercial we should do
something you gotta do something to
really move some [ __ ] products that's
all
honestly that's i know i get ahead of
myself that was the only reason i wanted
the cards
is because i wanted to make the
commercial i saw it with a bunch of
little kids playing cards making fun of
you
who's got the budget for this little
kids playing cards
i get your three kids here right now no
it's black and white and it's fully
drinking water with dinner all sad yeah
it's like it's
spilling on them and stuff he can't plug
a cord in or something regular pack of
cards don't know how to use them he's
got two gallons of whole milk and a
[ __ ] thing of lasagna
oh it's good stuff so hap kippy you're
the best man thanks
this is why this guy [ __ ] runs the
operation he's [ __ ] steam charge in
the head
he's like custer over here but he wins
now yeah we got some biz but with work
comes reward you work hard yeah and he
plays hard too
sure all right yeah some of his high
falutin german wife
so all right hold on you know scott back
we yeah typically
you know uh so i've realized i am trash
and it was so for the listener i went to
it was my one year anniversary
over the weekend and i went to a very uh
a very nice
uh spa and the poconos fully you
wouldn't even be allowed on the property
this place
this is the nicest place it was insane
crazy
that's why people like that's how they
came from coal miners leaving a shift in
front of the hotel
that's how they keep people like you out
you think it's the poconos
like wakanda hide in plain sight you
know what i mean so
i was very expensive place and um uh
so i heard the number it's high yeah
it's hot you could go to europe
for two weeks for this price we need you
to buy these cars
um so my wife wanted to do it so we we
did it
and uh i gotta tell you i so you know
you've seen mike
uh so i pull up and i don't know how
nice this place is but it's a valley i
made fun of it it's a valet
kind of place you don't have a valet i
do not have a valet car
you look like ace ventura yeah i got any
more gum
it's it's a i would have never i would
have rented a car for the 400
for the weekend i was just gonna say
that i didn't know so we pull up it's
this windy snow
and you pull up to like the first hut
you know what i mean like you're getting
into like a gated community kind of
right there's like the window and the
there's the exit and the entrance is
there a guy up there
there's a guy in the in the hut really
because ryan mrs
hey what's your name first he thought i
was [ __ ] casing the joint
he thought i got lost or something hey
who ordered pizza
dude right then i lost buddy right then
i kind of knew
something was up it's not gonna be like
you park in a parking lot and carry your
own bags in kind of place
um and what dude my car is so shitty
dude it's so [ __ ] it's so tragic it's
shittier than you would think
yeah and they're going to see it soon on
the patreon when we do that yeah yeah
yeah um so dude
it so he's like yeah just bend around
and stay to the right
sir i'm sorry my car doesn't turn left
i can only go you got a jug handle
somewhere around here
jersey rules oh dude man and
my wife's just so excited because the
place is picture at dude it's like the
winding light
i'm surprised you honestly i'm surprised
you've gotten this far with her
it's a classy lady believe i met her
she's clearly
she's a classy brawler i did she drives
around with you
well you have a bench seat in the front
don't you it's bench seat it's not a
bench
first of all it's a 2006 mercury montego
2005.
[Laughter]
i think it was the last year they made
them so it's a mint condition it's
it's the collector's idea you know it's
bad when they don't make your car
anymore
and not for a good reason real bad it's
real bad
i uh so we're like he's like yeah just
pull around to the right
under the awning and i'm like you don't
park i'm like this ain't good so i'm
like maybe he's gonna do the
maybe he's gonna do you drop the bags
off then you park your own car but i
as i'm getting closer to the front
entrance i'm like yo this is bad this is
[ __ ]
i'm gonna look like a [ __ ] schmuck
dude i got coffee i treat the
dude i treat the back seat like a
dumpster we just like launch [ __ ]
mcdonald's bags over our shoes that's
why that's why it's so great to have a
car man it's the best all right so
i do i have i have empty i parking
tickets are everywhere
well also too because we've been filming
so i'm like i'm not going to clean it
because we're going to film it i want to
give that i want to give an honest
reputation so it's a little even
trashier there's literal trash and i'm
i'm trashy as i don't you i don't use my
trunk because there's like an air
conditioner there's like a log in there
there's a broom
you have an air conditioner in your
trunk yeah
are you kidding me is that to keep
weight for the snow
[Laughter]
dude that's you have an air conditioner
in your trunk
it's a window unit why don't you put it
in the closet in the apartment
i don't cause when we moved it was like
the last thing i just left it in there
oh my god what it's a brand new you're
my boss
that you haven't oh my god so i think
that's dangerous
why because if you have to hit the
brakes it could come through the back
seat
dude you are your mom your body fully
relaxed that could get you in the back
of the skull god damn it
[Laughter]
ah shout out to my mom and dad i was
with them for a couple of days oh i know
because i get the residual anxiety
we are a whole nest of crazy down there
jesus but i would never change it for
the world i love you um
so i pull up and i'm still trying to
assess the situation and these [ __ ]
bag boys move quick
he was tapping the trunk to pop it i'm
like yo
nah dude we don't do drunk around here
he's going like this on the back
i almost don't reverse
snooping around a man's trunk [ __ ]
heisenberg over here
stay away from my car's all dented it's
been hit by like city buses and you keep
rolling
it's bad it doesn't look good it's
gotten progress it's a city car
so the luggage is in the back seat i'm a
backseat luggage kind of guy
there's always have been always have
been why you open it
it's not like i have like proper luggage
i have an overnight i'm aware of that
um so i go yo the bags are in the back
and dude and
it's like it just all happened so i felt
like that when you
when you get hit yeah you know when you
get whacked by them you have cash on
hand
no cash on hand but i've already looked
up it's a no cash place
no cash none it's all in a room you put
on a room you're kind of you're kind of
my kind of place
you know put on room 305 or 306 whatever
whatever's clever daddy
no you find a guy that looks at it looks
like you that's what you do when you're
first staying
you scope out a couple who could be you
is he a chubby guy baldi yeah it's him
i'm mr childsworth this is my wife yeah
man so
it was like i had like a half empty box
so like i was like yeah just these bags
in there and he hangs he's like this is
it and then i felt like a piece of [ __ ]
i'm like yes is it what do you mean
sir would you like your arby's would you
like this bag of burger king my lord
you don't mind a curly fries the benz is
in the shop
there he is the mcmuffin coming in i had
the worst i had the worst car on the
property for sure and it just
really means and that's anybody who
worked there too oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah it was they had to
be talking about me
of course so he goes there's keeping an
eye on you at checkout
this broad makes a move for the door
tackler there was a half empty
um there was a half empty coke zero on
the floor
rolling around you know just because i'm
[ __ ] trash i don't know what you want
from me
so he goes i'm going to bring in the
soda too and i'm like now
you don't want this so he goes they
explode so he like puts it in a loose
booth that was like on the
i was he's like we don't though it'll
freeze it's so cold up there and
although i guess it'll explode
he goes what do you got mentos in it
what's going on
i don't know dude i was already sewing
back i'm like yeah man [ __ ] shove it
up your ass we're all like here let's
[ __ ]
keep it moving take the clothes take the
take the bags to the room
hey gang quick reminder about the stereo
app
me and the big man are on there every
thursday and i gotta tell you it's a
good
time yeah we're having fun over there
gang we do a little show every thursday
night at nine o'clock
uh where basically we just take your
guys questions uh the app's fantastic
you can leave a message it's all done
live right there
we're having a really really fun time
chopping up with you guys yeah guys it's
easy you just record a message
and some of the questions are home runs
for sure
it's a lot of fun it's a good time you
get involved go to www.stereo.com
kevinryan or slash h foley
sure sign up using our link we get to
wet our beak a little bit it's a good
time
come join us now back to the show
it was bad dude it was it made me it was
a moment and we'll talk i'll be
we'll get into this morning we'll get to
some we have the patreon questions we're
gonna get to
uh in a minute but get those patreon
numbers up help the kid get a decent
automobile
that is the first thing i'm gonna buy
like a [ __ ] used you know
you kippy get a nice car i don't like
cars give me a deal on a montego
they can't use the trunk it comes with a
free air conditioner that's
crazy so it just made me realize like i
am
trapped like to the core yeah
i was so embarrassed i weighed on my
head all weekend i was so embarrassed i
was gonna have to go back down and they
were gonna have to get my car again
like i was like i wanted to be the same
bellboy
so another guy wasn't in my car it would
have been great if it wouldn't like it
would have broke down right there i know
i used to everything you used to get
stuck in park and you remember that it
would get stuck in a park for a long
time you had to like just like
[ __ ] sit there so i just have to
leave a note like hey get stuck in park
sometimes yeah that's the guard that's
i'm trash that is the definition of
garbage and i think we've discussed this
when something breaks and you just that
you add the extra step
to work around it you don't get it fixed
oh yeah remote controls blinds and stuff
like that
you have to jiggle it you know jiggle
the handle on the on the thing yeah
while i'm baking any time it started
making making a new noise i just
turned the volume up yeah we
self-flushed our toilet i think most of
my high school years
through the back yeah you lift up the
thing and give it a little bit every
time
roughly yeah i think it gets to the
point where you stop putting the back on
then you're just that
you're an open camera but there was a
paper clip holding it for a little while
yeah that's bad yeah oh i'm sorry
mr air conditioning trunk that's a
logical place to keep the spare cold
keep you on ice oh whatever man yeah man
i'm trying
it really it really bothered me i gotta
get i gotta do better and that's the
message to everybody you don't you can
be trash but
it's we're just as lazy you can do
better you know what i mean keep trying
keep trying you know one day you'll be
in an 08 camry you'll get there
i uh i also realized how trashy i was
this weekend
now i got a nice tv i got a nice
apartment you know what i mean my girl
does well
um but we got the smart tv but we didn't
get the
extra like the bluetooth and stuff like
that so the way i
the way i watch my shoes all right we
have our streaming apps you know i mean
our amazons or whatever
but i figured out that i can download
apps onto my tv and then i could use my
parents
sign-in information for their case you
know like a 45-year-old man
you're breaking milestones about a
[ __ ] air conditioner in a trunk
mine's in the closet all right get your
own netflix what are we doing i have my
own netflix
but i have to use their sign-in so
anyway so i'm trying to watch the big
game you know what i mean it's sunday
night
first of all you know no offense i don't
want to shoot myself on the foot for any
uh future
acting work but cbs with the super bowl
what are we doing here come on i don't
get it oh they're trash
come on fox or nbc that's it i'll have
it on espn
cbs they're notoriously the worst with
football
and i had to [ __ ] download the cbs
app
okay the cbs all they don't just have
like a regular app and you got to use
like your mom's login
no i couldn't use it that that's what
was [ __ ]
there's a couple comcast guys out there
looking for me i'll tell you that
no shot my whole family uses my aunt's
[ __ ] directv
if they ever crack down on that there's
gonna be a ricoh case [ __ ] nine
states
everybody's getting everything the whole
mcmuffin family is going down direct tv
is real garbage
yeah but i couldn't just sign in with my
tv provider
they have you jumping through hoops you
had to sign up 14.99 but a free trial
for the week
so obviously i'm going to watch the game
and then put the kibosh on that front i
got 15 bucks that you don't do
i already canceled it because it didn't
[ __ ] work so i
sat there and we had to use the internet
explorer on our [ __ ]
hdmi cable no we had it we just you know
because there's a there's an internet
explorer
like you know oh yeah so i just i
watched the [ __ ] game
on the internet yeah but i couldn't get
it to go full screen
so i'm sitting there watching it like a
[ __ ] jerk off yeah that's well you're
yeah that's
and i felt like a loser in front of my
lady you know what i mean because it's
like you know i can't even provide that
for
not to mention i was about 30 seconds
away from winning [ __ ] some serious
cash
yeah in the first quarter almost hit
that pool
oh almost hit that pool baby i almost
have my toes wet i would have been a
[ __ ] guest
and i didn't tell her okay so we had
ordered some we had ordered some uh some
tacos
all right and we're sitting there and i
didn't tell her so it gets down to 30
seconds it's [ __ ]
three nothing i got 3-0 in the pool and
i'm
like she's like talking to me i i
couldn't even i
i couldn't even pay attention keep it
cool i was just [ __ ] down something
just waiting for it tacos and a thousand
bucks good
night daddy oh the big man is living and
then the goat [ __ ] put one in the
[ __ ] gronkowski in the end zone
[ __ ] sank my whole day
and then she was saying i'm something
and i i just [ __ ] snapped and i was
like [ __ ]
we almost just won a [ __ ] thousand
dollars
i told you to shut up you wore a wrong
pair of socks
yeah you got the remotes in the wrong
place
[Laughter]
so we're both trash man yeah let's be
honest
buddy it was never it's never more
apparent than when you're hanging out
with classy people or at a classy place
in your [ __ ] trash
yeah and it was just like reassured over
this and i was like oh i've made the
right career path to
bank my whole career path on [ __ ]
garbage 100 percent my
my me and my mom showed how trashy we
were uh screaming at each other
during the blizzard trying to get the
call because i was there for the
blizzard
and they got this this plow guy that
comes and does it i bet you
she yeah what what i forgot you i
thought this is a patreon episode for a
minute shout out to paddy
uh but i had to pull my car out so he
can come in and plow it but we had
already had like a [ __ ]
come on you're lobbing these up i'm a
hack at heart dude come on
talking about i gotta come over to plow
you what do you want me to do here
my hands are tied anyway
so the car gets stuck getting out of the
driveway and the neighbors are out there
this nice couple is across the street
they're like shoveling their walk
and me and her just go [ __ ] going
back and forth i wish i would have never
had you
treats like i'm a little kid i'm a 45
year old man i know how to [ __ ] rock
a car out
put on some skinner then let it go daddy
gotta cut off on but you know what's
funny it's the simple things that make
us garbage
because i had on sunday i had stopped at
starbucks drive through in the suburbs
it's worth it that's nice that's dude
i'm a big app got
a drive we don't get drive-throughs in
the city ah the drive-through the
suburbs come
all right what are we doing here this
this [ __ ] dump let's get out man
where the [ __ ] grass is green um but
i got a bottle of water from [ __ ]
starbucks
and uh i left it in the car so it had
been in there for two days
in like 30 degrees cream and cold and i
was in there and i was in the car
waiting [ __ ] i found it in there
man it was like two weeks vacation all
right everything's coming up h
i probably just need some tacos cold
water and a [ __ ]
instagram and a close one internet bowl
internet explorer
good times um all right let's get into
some questions this is a pretty good
segue uh we gotta
i gotta tell you the patreon guys when
you obviously you know if i'm sure you
do uh when you sign up for patreon we'll
read your questions
and they did not disappoint this run
there is some [ __ ]
haters in this thing uh being the fact
that i was just away and i
i don't know if we've ever talked about
this to be honest this is from tony p on
a patreon
tony p the place to be look at the place
to be
have you ever taken something from the
mini bar and tried to replace it
no i'd never that was that's like hot
water burn baby for me
yeah because any time we were kids and
we were in a hotel
that we were we were under a gestapo
regime
to even look at it penalty of death yeah
when you're a little 10 year old fat kid
and you're at some [ __ ]
holiday inn in mississippi what a sweet
tooth
and you got a [ __ ] nine dollar pack
of m m staring at you
man it takes everything you have takes
everything you got
little fat foley like indiana jones
oh just laying in there like [ __ ]
apocalypse now staring at the ceiling
he's [ __ ] dying knowing those
eminem's are right there
i never that was also a thing my family
we didn't [ __ ] touch them
like that was not even a thing first of
all i don't i
i think i've been in a hotel with my mom
maybe once we done we weren't hotel
people
we were down the shore for the sleep in
the car we were down the shore people
um and then with my dad i don't know
we were never really in hotels that
often okay um
but one time we went out to i went out
to la uh for my 18th birthday my brother
and my cousin
really yeah yeah it was like a package
trip that like my aunt wanted a silent
auction for charity or something and
she was like here yeah go she should
very very close i'm very happy i was
joking
a package trip yeah silent auction
though
that ain't bad yeah it was all whatever
it was just hope to give that back
though
my family does a couple of silent
auctions for my yeah we're not talking
about 50 50 raffles no they do it nice
i've never been
well you got to give 25 back to the
house to help tammy get a new jersey get
out of here
tammy needs new veneers no there's a
foundation in our family
it really is okay i don't get i don't
get to go to those kind of things yeah
who would want you there i think they
asked me to open up one here
the foley foundation has water damage
it's got a rap problem got termites got
to knock this thing down
um but i went out we went out to la one
time and
uh i don't know what happened but me and
my brother and my cousin and they're
they're two very
street smart guys the people my brother
and my cousin right i'll give you that
they're very [ __ ]
you know they're scheming they're
planning they're if i was hemmed up i'd
want
you'd want yeah i'd want your brother
he's a [ __ ] quick mover smart
and pretty crazy i imagine at some point
he'll be brought into the operation at
some point
this yeah maybe i i could see it maybe
my brother brought in two if we get the
number no we don't need more foleys get
though i'm trying to i'm trying to use
the polaroid
you want man well then i'll swap them
out i ain't doing humans
giving each other noogies every episode
hey get over me he's a sharp kid main
street wall street doesn't matter he
moves it
what are you cnn main street wall street
shut up
gamestop bitcoin whatever that means
coin dogecoin whatever give me it that
thing got a hammy that coin got a hammy
um i uh so we went out and it was like
there was like a 12 pack of coors light
in the
there was it was there was a bunch of
beers in not like it was for you you
know what i mean
it was a very nice hotel what is that
what a six or a course like no but it
wasn't your picture and it's wrong it
was like a cribs one where it was like
six cores lights six heinekens six
modelos
bottles or cans bottles i think or maybe
i forget
it was it was done it was like classy it
was like done well
because we were like we got there we're
like yeah we'll just [ __ ] drink these
as a pre-game and then we'll buy a
12-pack
it's a great idea yeah they got lasers
or something because they were like
and we'll charge you for the 16 beers
they're like
[ __ ] at like 18 a click wait how did
they know i don't know
wait i don't know somebody can write in
i don't know if there's lasers wait
there's lasers or scales there's a
weight sensor inside the many bar
yeah it doesn't matter you can pick up a
bottle look at it yeah well they knew we
didn't take six out of the whole thing
at one point it was empty so there's no
waiting center in a college boy
[ __ ] fridge i don't they they they
had us
dead to rights i don't know if they had
surveillance footage or something
they had us we couldn't we would get the
manager get this guy
dude they had to payroll like that it
was like the bourne ultimatum in there
yeah
nine times out of ten if you're asking
for the manager you're in the wrong oh
yeah
it's the last act of a desperate man
right there let me talk to your manager
let me talk how do i know you didn't
drink them beers where were you last
night at 2 30 were you in my room
wow toby's got some info there's lasers
or something
all right check this out most consumers
know that if you drink anything from the
mini bar in their hotel room they'll be
charged but did you know
some hotels now automatically charge
your bill if you so much as touch
the snack tray even if you don't eat
anything damn you trigger the sensor
there's no putting it back
there's a sensor it's like mission
impossible dude i don't know
it's just a bunch of lasers and then a
six-pack on the other end i gotta dive
[ __ ] ridiculous they got us we tried
we fought but they were like nah
it's only it was like 300 bucks like
that the mini bar
that whole operation not been they're
starting to wean away from that a little
bit
and now i mean i don't i can't remember
the last hotel i was in like a proper
they might have like a water big bottle
of water something for like 18
but that really is a [ __ ] like what you
don't need to charge 15
for [ __ ] a snickers bar like what are
you doing why why
you're coming and going dude it's [ __ ]
up yeah what are you gonna do um but
fantastic
question tony pay shout out to tony
amazing uh another fridge related
question this is from david smith do you
store things on top of your fridge
uh not at the foleys growing up yes
we have a couple of things up there
garage fridge forget about it it's like
a [ __ ] game of jenga
out there yeah you got paper towels
[ __ ] charcoal all this stuff the
other thing sure but now what do you got
if i go to your apartment right now what
do you got on top of the fridge
okay i could use some help over at our
place really it's
not good you shouldn't have anything
theoretically however new york city
apartment
guy like you
okay i can
i can
it's see the air conditioner in the
trunk and the water heater on top of the
fridge
you've got things i i hate things on the
top of the fridge face
put a d that way i hate when you hit me
with a lion when i know it's from
i know what it's from guy like you
what's that from
uh it's loosely from seinfeld people
like you yeah so how many how much would
it give you for a bag yeah i like you
yeah yeah don't look like you know what
you're doing it's all from seinfeld
yeah come on um get the card game uh
this is what's acceptable maybe
a couple of nice bowls all right
the trashiest thing is having open boxes
of cereal up there
which i know most of our listeners have
open boxes of cereal on top
and they aren't fully closed either you
got the one flaps up
yeah it's tough to keep those clean yeah
yeah i'm always amazed
to see people's serial box etiquette
that's mine's horrible different from
like like because in our family there
was two or three bucks there was like
honey nut cheerios
and maybe a raisin bran for my dad and
something else and
and they didn't last long but i've been
to like friends houses or like even
as an adult and they have like six boxes
of cereal
like an old box of like you know like
frosted flakes that they didn't eat
that was the shelf life yeah on
seriously we had a couple just
sitting there well it would be like if
somebody came up and we
moved merchandise and if they got down
to a certain point foley's like their
carbs
yeah if it got down to a certain point
she would start dishing out
uh party mix bowls in the morning ah i
hated those because it was always no
because it was always the crumbs too
with that i love the crumbs
give me a hearty what on sugar cereal i
do the last bowl
of sugar cereal is the best because you
get like [ __ ] eight grams of sugar in
that
because the dust is all in the bottom
how'd the cardia have the cardiologist
go again today how did i find out
tomorrow
nuclear stress test tomorrow sounds cool
yeah it's gonna be an explosion i gotta
wear a spacesuit
[Laughter]
dressed like homer got the big got the
big aluminum foil thing on with the
tongs
where do you need me doc i feel like i'm
working spacex
ah let me let me throw this curveball at
you go ahead t-bone where are you guys
at with
using the oven for storage like my
girlfriend's mom's
getting her [ __ ] thanksgiving tray in
the oven you got to pull it out anytime
you want to make a pizza that
that i give you trays are fine yeah
trays yeah we have like four cookies but
thanks
for the thanksgiving trays if you're
only using it on thanksgiving you gotta
take it out that's
[ __ ] that's weird but if every i mean
like if you
oh yeah we have like a pan with the tray
and then it's like sure you need it yeah
yeah especially in new york you got it
i'm not putting [ __ ] watermelons and
stuff in there i don't have
[ __ ] produce in my oven it's got
laundry [ __ ] animal
yeah now my girl will put a pizza an
empty pizza box in there
and you got to be real careful you burn
a [ __ ] torch
i caught her who was that lorenzo's
that was something i was thinking of too
is uh because of my pizza place shout
out to [ __ ] taste italy fantastic
[ __ ] pizza
place but they don't have their own
boxes they must be getting surplus from
joints that close
i've never gotten he knows and stuff
i've never gotten the same pizza box
from [ __ ] this place everybody's
hemmed up in a pandemic stuff
production's down for a lot of places
wait wait pre panda
back in the 90s yeah you'd never get the
same box twice
yeah yeah um yeah that's garbage man
it's trash it is what's on top of your
refrigerator well should we keep the
she she's got a produce basket up there
uh
is there fruit in it yeah that's not bad
no yeah it's like you know
do you ever forget it up there and it
gets real mealy
it has not regularly but like i'd be
lying if i said
you know you never pulled out like a
[ __ ] soft uh you know you ever
forgotten
you ever forget an avocado somewhere
holy [ __ ] no they move they go
they don't hang out too long at all oh
yeah no yeah i'll eat two avocados a day
if i can't like we're pretty bad with
fruit
oh really well yeah we'll go we'll go in
i was too busy with the bottom of the
lucky charms we'll go in with the best
intentions and then like
i'm surprised how long like oranges
lemons and limes last
takes a long time to kill them they're
like denzel i'm telling you dude
you really got to work on them um yeah
but like yeah so i have like the bag of
clementines in there and then
i do have an empty uh bag of clementine
i have an empty bottle of whiskey on top
of it as well
i like i don't know i ca i to me it's
classy whiskey it's like 50
it's called a writer's tears it's like
55 bucks and we have she built a wine
holder
a few years ago like a wooden one and
she put that in there so the wine holder
is on there it's like a wine rack
and the empty bottles in there is there
any full bottles of wine in there
no i just it's just one it just holds
one it's like an upside down wooden like
little
um okay art crafts thing
all right yeah we're trying i mean yeah
i have an empty bottle of whiskey on top
of my [ __ ]
fridge displayed you shouldn't really
have i think she did it as a joke but
now that it's up there i'm like i'm not
taking that down
and you know what i mean it's like it's
just there now here's the thing most
classy people
okay now i'm half into this because you
don't have the whole top of my
refrigerator there's a cabinet above it
but most classy individuals have the
cabinets the refrigerator is
is you know the cabinet fixtures
you should only be able to see the front
of your refrigerator if you can see sure
if you can see three sides of your
refrigerator
things ain't going great somebody posted
a picture have you ever been
to somebody's house where the stove
isn't in a line where you can see the
side of the stove
yo get out it's got to be in the middle
or on the end
it can't just be at like but like yeah
you can't i think a friend of ours who's
been a recent guest in this
i believe his parents the the oven is
just
by itself against the wall ah yeah
that's a tough one that's a
tough look yeah i can't do it you can do
if you can see behind the oven yeah it's
no good
no good no good at all oh man this is uh
this is from austin on the patreon
uh did your parents this is a [ __ ]
homer did your parents have a filing
cabinet growing up
with a bunch of [ __ ] keepers and like
uh we had one and i'm like i remember
like
every few years like no nothing's in
here that we need it's like a box of
envelopes and you know like
yeah old taxes or something nothing's
good in there my dad has the whole
uh the roll the roll top desk that was
big the big one
oh yeah when he went when when he when
he left the navy
and was and was doing insurance he you
know he worked out of the house for a
little while
he had the whole roll top tech look at
norman rockwell back there
yeah you open those drawers [ __ ]
nothing nothing nothing
three paper clips and a cigar cutter
yeah exactly there's like a yellow paper
clip there's always like the odd one
that's stuck
in there from the person you bought it
from some paperweight that we've had
since i was a kid
yeah people set up the home office
you're not doing that much that you need
your own home off let alone a fight like
a fireproof
locking filing cabinet yeah when you're
little let's keep it in a drunk drawer
let's go
when you're a little kid on a board
saturday looking through all that stuff
rooting through [ __ ]
i thought i was gonna find cash i love
roots i have found cash before snooping
around
stupid yeah like i told you enough where
i'm like are you a spy what's happening
here
periodically i would go through the the
uh the closet
i've said this on the podcast at by the
front door you know in the summer
i'll root through everybody's pockets to
see what's i do that when i go home
you'll find something
now that i'm not home they're a little
looser with the keys i bet
i'm i'm digging through pockets dude in
august in august you did you dig through
a ski jacket it might come out with a
dub or something
back back in kleenex the filing cabinet
in a house fire is just the black box to
a sad existence
i only didn't even clear 32k last year
poor son of a [ __ ]
ah man that's a [ __ ] good one file
cabinets
trash tough um we keep our stuff in a
bag
hidden a bag like a like a bag
what do you mean like a bag you're
saying like a bag a bag
like a plastic bag what are they called
a courier bag that's where we keep our
important documents like what's in there
social security card birth certificate
um what do you need your social security
card for
you know no i flew with it one time
yeah remember i told you when i was down
yeah atlanta i got jammed up i didn't
have a [ __ ]
i didn't have a license and i i got i
got into the uh the laughing skull
comedy festival
and i had to [ __ ] make a move uh this
is post 911 too they let me fly with
just a [ __ ] social security card you
had something else though
you did i remember my bank card
luigi's bank and one of the old pizza
boxes
for my guy um all right this next one
this is from katie woolston
she also she had i remember she had the
really funny one about using the
uh the massages at stops or the mall
she says have you ever entered your name
into one of the free car giveaways at
the mall
to try to win like the whatever's in the
over by the strawbridges or whatever
you have to put a business card in there
no you like sign up like and you put
your name in the bin or whatever and you
can win a free car
no my dad's throwing a couple of
business cards in the bowl in a [ __ ]
like elise [ __ ] chi-chi's
six footer the more times you're in
there the better off your chances are
there's no dude let me tell you
something for my money there's nothing
better than a [ __ ] six-foot hoagie
i love one of those that's great it's
just a hoagie the size doesn't matter
you walk into a party and one of those
things are [ __ ]
there man you pull up a chair what'd you
guys get
hey you start on the other end i love it
i never did it for me it was cool i went
to like a super bowl party or something
with one one
time we're like oh this is crazy but i'm
like i don't get it no we never went for
that kiosk [ __ ] at the mall
no maybe if there's a dodge something
sitting there yeah that's what i'm
saying the car's there
you know they you sign up they're just
collecting information or whatever
those days are over man what trying to
win a car at the mall what do you mean
hey nobody goes to the mall anymore yeah
i went to them all in the way so
somewhere
uh not too long ago and it was like this
saddest [ __ ] thing in the world
malls were great it was like there's
like three stores open the auntie anne's
was closed you know if times are bad
auntie anne's is closing forget about it
i know i know what you hope was the h
m let the chinese just take over put
down our put down our arms it's over
yeah [ __ ] auntie anza's closing
we used to go i told you to joanne's nut
house i know that's a regional
place it sounds like a concert venue
come on down to joey's
house it was like a candy by the pound
kiosk in the mall
oh yeah we used to go to you're not all
nuts yeah
but you are trash yeah shout out to you
we're not all right
we've talked my aunt had an in with the
lady that worked at this one of course
of course
of course you guys had a candy
connection uh we used to walk out of
there [ __ ] live in the
duffel bag bring your filing cabinet
non-pre-l's chocolate-covered cashews
the works
whatever you wanted go ahead it's all in
a house joanne's picking it up
it's all on joanne
did you ever have an did your mom or dad
ever have an in anywhere
where are you yeah we're all ins we're
all we're irish trash so you've gone to
a place like to eat
and you got it for free never for free
that would get they would have paid me
yeah no they wouldn't take it they go to
a place where like they're friends but
they've been friends with the owner for
like ever
do they have a month well they have like
a monthly account at they're like
monthly just yeah well billy like they
just like they just get
a bill at the end of the month really a
lot of times yeah some [ __ ] bar in
your hometown
it's a nicer i mean nicer place what
happens when the kid comes over with the
check
they don't they know they either you
know
wiseguy never pays for a drink really
yeah that's pretty cool my cousin said
it best shout out to him hold on a
second what do they leave the kid
ah they [ __ ] grease them grease them
he gets a 20 or whatever
whatever yeah all right uh-huh that's
pretty good yeah it's not bad and they
settle up at the end of the month i
guess
i don't know i've been there where no
check has showed up i had a guy that i
used to see periodically
that i had i had a i had a tab with
it wasn't food yeah but you know sure
yeah
it was a topping just a topic yeah it
was an accessory let's say
but i would just settle up with him at
the end of the month my uh
i'd make him chase me a little bit yeah
dude threw your phone in the river
was that you calling holy [ __ ] was that
yeah is it the 31st already
but yeah um that's a good feeling my
cousin has always said it we always had
a guy we had a meat guy he still have a
mika we got a
deli guy we got you know we have a guy
like yeah it's we we have a guy forever
my cousins at best he said we're like
the kennedys without the money
and i was like dude that's pretty
[ __ ] good it's just a bunch of irish
meatheads and all know people that can
[ __ ] move stuff around for you know
what i mean yeah it's good
it's good um shout out to garrett this
was from garrett
this sometimes you read one and it just
[ __ ] hits you dude this is from
garrett
when you shop online do you price low to
high
hold on a second let me tweak the
filters real quick
[ __ ] a best-selling baby give me the low
oh yeah
man that hit me like a ton of bricks
i'm all low to high sure big low to high
filter filter filter less than 50
sometimes
absolutely yeah i remember who's got the
cash to do that people do
people do well out there also shout out
to the guy who tweeted
toby you didn't say it the guy you eat
it today because uh the arty garbage
page patreon is the only patreon i
joined because i feel like i make more
money than the host
i was [ __ ] crying
i was i was like buddy you do bingo
we could have 10 000 more people join
you make more than 15
g's a year you got us cold
are you on welfare uh man dead door i
saw that yeah i'm a big
high guy yeah always looking for a part
i remember craigslist looking for
apartments you can set that at zero
yeah they're like what's the minimum on
my [ __ ] freebie daddy oh let's go
you pay me that's what where's that
option oh man
ah man [ __ ] love these that was a
[ __ ] homer a couple of home runs this
week
i know this is another really good one
i've seen it uh this is from sean
growing up did you have a puzzle glued
together that was a hanging piece of art
in your house
i saw that somewhere that that is so
[ __ ] trashy
i don't even know how you do that i
don't know either but to think that
that's art
i mean maybe if a kid i don't know it
shouldn't be happening i know that much
no
that that house definitely has a
hand-sewn quilt
somewhere in the house yeah well i never
liked quilts
did you ever go over to sleep over a
kid's house i'm an afghan guy
they gave you the quilt i'm like you
might as well give me the ring to a
sixer this ain't gonna [ __ ] work dude
wait hold on a quilt meaning like an
amish quilt
i like a quilt i mean with like no i got
it wrong i like a quilt i'm not an
afghan guy
the ones that are like yarn they don't
do anything get your toe caught in them
that's what i'm saying
that's what i said it's like a six-pack
holder yeah i don't need that thing
no yeah yeah those things are brutal no
we tried to do the puzzles with my dad
this summer
you know i mean stimulate the brain
lasts about two seconds nudie ones
a couple of playboys
here you go old man just stole the tits
he's up in the bathroom you gotta go in
there and get him he's waiting he stole
the tits and went to the bed
i'm so he was my dad was always real
classy with that stuff there was never
any magazines or anything like that
tv guide maybe but there was no like
magazine laying in there no but he
wasn't like one of those guys that had
like a nudie calendar in the garage
i used to go to my stepdad's car shop
and he had to snap
on the big red snap-on uh you know what
there's
oh that's not what they're called yeah
snap-ons those things are great by the
way dude a couple of [ __ ]
couple of nudies hanging on that and i
used to
make up excuses to walk by this thing oh
where's the refrigerator is it this way
out of bathtub over here this week
buddy catch me lingering and they had to
know
they had to know kippy had a little
stinger gun oh
man no kidding yeah if you had yeah i
mean all people aren't doing that now
right
no i don't think because porn you're not
going to like a [ __ ] garage and they
have like a naked woman
hung up i would have who needs porn like
that yeah i would have to assume no
it's not looking over t-bones got one on
the wall
[ __ ] jenna jameson's over there i i
don't think so i think that would
definitely turn off some some customers
yeah
my dad had boxes of playboys growing up
really he was that guy man that's why
you're weird dude man no kidding
i always that explains a haircut i
always thought he was homeschooled for a
little while i remember my brother
and his friends stash one in the creek
down the driveway because that's where
you keep born in the 90s sure in the
woods
and i came i came home and they were it
had gotten wet
and they were on the driveway trying to
reassemble it like like a paper shredder
outside of enron
put the [ __ ] case back together
[ __ ] national treasure i got a labia
what do you got
wait hold on are these playboys that
your dad collected in his youth
or were they playboys that he was
getting in the mail while you were alive
not classics so when he was a kid
it was like he would have been like a
college aged kid and he kept them as a
collector's
type deal sure did he ever has a creeper
yeah man does your dad have a beard
obviously i felt like
i felt like a fortune teller right there
you're kind of a beard with some
moccasins i bet he is
does he have circle glasses uh
no glasses for sure though english
professor
are they on a string no okay but he's
got a glasses case
all day ponytail no ever did rock and
earring at one point
oh this guy's got playboys
jesus wow wait where were the playboys
in a place where they were readily
available
uh yeah so he was still looking at them
no no no i mean they were readily
available to a couple of sneaky bastards
like
i mean that was probably like oh they're
in a box in this closet or something
i couldn't my dad never had any of that
[ __ ] nothing like that i could
my mom would have [ __ ] lost it she
would have found a playboy
that's what you're looking at harry
you're sicko
you're sick beastie that happened to me
man
i uh i got caught in fourth grade
[Laughter]
shooting doggy style i got caught in
fourth grade by my teacher going like
this grabbing
grabbing my crotch to the class we're
like ah like yeah you know to somebody
in class
i'm listening and um
she's like my teacher miss cooper great
great teacher
she's not watching freaked out all right
she like brought me outside
you know look at they bring out they get
serious yeah you know what i mean
like you know like i done something
perverted brings me outside she's like i
can't believe you did that
if you do anything else for the rest of
the day i'm calling your parents
sure enough i got [ __ ] pinched like
two periods later
pulling my ass talking out of my ass
doing the thing where you throw the
pencils up to the drop ceiling oh that
was big busted cold
had me dead to the right nowhere to run
your name was on the pencil yeah nowhere
to run
so i was like i was like please please
don't call my mom please please please
[ __ ] whatever so sure enough
i get home you want to grab your wiener
did it teach you oh she did it real
slick she did she
it was very very slick the way she did
it so
i come home she's like your teacher
called you were throwing pencils at the
ceiling huh
throwing pencils at the ceiling now do
you know you're dead you know
if she's bringing are you going to [ __ ]
she knows everything there's no way the
teacher's calling and just talking about
the pencils well i assumed that that
when i walked in i was going to walk
into a firing squad all right but i just
she hands you a cigarette
what a hers what would you like on your
tombstone
cheese and pepperoni corners there
measuring me out now so i walked in and
she's like you know you're throwing
pencils at the ceiling you know just you
know because
nowadays the mom would defend the kid
not all the time but yeah but back then
man it didn't there could be
it could be here saying conjecture
conjecture i'm guilty no matter what
yeah they were always going to side with
whoever it was never going to be on my
side
so she hits me i agree with him 100 yeah
then rightly so i was a [ __ ]
little dirtball little kid um stealing
change out of her pockets what do you
mean i'm a scumbag what do you want
yeah [ __ ] rico charges so she hits me
with that you're throwing pencils at the
ceiling blah blah blah blah then she
lets it go whatever you're grounded for
whatever
so then i did something later that night
okay that like pissed her off she sat on
it she's sad on it
shout out to patty cold blooded all
right [ __ ] cold blood she's sad on it
so fast forward to it's [ __ ] eight
o'clock
i'm getting in the bath all right my
bath order's running i'm naked
in my bathroom let me see a little prick
and all of a sudden the door kicks open
and she goes
and whoever taught you this and she does
it to me yeah was she wearing
i'm sorry paddy i love it let me tell
you something man
you want to talk about wait start over
start from the beginning you want to
talk about repressing your
sexual desires being naked in [ __ ] i
don't know
sixth grade and your mom coming in
whoever it talks like your mom was
seeing your bra joel when you were since
she kicked open the door she snuck a
peek what do you mean oh no she hit you
with de-lousing powder
i got this rambo
[Laughter]
who does the joke about that about rambo
how they how they were like really mean
to him for no reason
it might be shane torres or something
somebody like that it's funny
um yeah she hit me with that that's
tough man
scoring trying to get an erection after
that [ __ ]
i got one now tell it again slower this
should be on patreon whoever taught you
this i don't ever want to stay in this
house again
and i was just like then i had to get in
the tub like a [ __ ] loser
wait you were taking tubbies when you
were 12. i was trying to relax
i had a [ __ ] stressful day what do
you mean they just [ __ ] bust at me
yeah i'm [ __ ] unwinding is that all
right oh my god having a [ __ ] ecto
cooler in a tub
what am i [ __ ] animal say russia you
got a rubber ducky at a parliament
yeah i'm trying to [ __ ] try to relax
before moonlighting comes on
the [ __ ] man
dude and we were close when i was a kid
because my dad would be traveling
so it'd be me and my mom that house
ain't big that bad room is right
now this is when we were in town line we
were [ __ ] on top of one
it's like a cold water flat as we said
before the air
yeah it scarred me do you have pubes yet
in sixth grade
i don't know maybe not i got them now
i'll tell you that
i didn't have no sophomore year in
college
[ __ ] late bloomer and those were
plugs
foley i feel like you're i feel like
your pubes look like albert einstein
they're jewish
[Laughter]
pulled on my pants hello yeah that's
exactly right
my pubes look like albert einstein after
he [ __ ] after a long night of solving
problems
it's [ __ ] just like it's
bad oh god that's good plus the little
guy
i gotta be i'm truth be told i don't
know we don't need it
okay truth not be told all right he's
shrinking
i think i said it's like benjamin
buttons down there i think
we talked we did this right
you're a big guy with a small brick and
a lot of hair what do you want i don't
know what he's doing he's going the
wrong way
get this kid down to spring training
i don't even think you know what you're
talking about sometimes really
i don't there's something dude you're so
funny that sometimes i go i don't think
he knows what comedy is
i think you should get really lucky for
a decade
because she'll make some jokes from like
oh no [ __ ] how what
dude man i was talking about the other
night kids got a hot handle about what
we were making
about me and ian were [ __ ] and you go
what it was the 80s we didn't know what
we were doing the japanese were all over
us
that was the funniest thing in the world
and then you just do something about
spring training who knows what the
[ __ ] going on
yeah what was the question i don't know
it was a good one low to high maybe i
forget yeah low to high was a load of
high how did we get to [ __ ]
oh it was playboys but we started our
yeah creepy mcmuffin over here somehow
ended up on your ween again
creepy mcmuffin senior that's a tie
never
i i loved all my friends dads but ones
that like we would find the porno
or find a video uh you know i always i
i looked at him differently i'll say
that i remember one time none of that
[ __ ] in my thing none of my uncles
none of that garbage okay
michael's never touched themselves i
mean we found online when
my buddy's dad like a stash of online
stuff when you would download like
pictures and maybe like 10 15 second
clips or whatever mainly pictures
it was before like you know proper porn
sites that you could go to so like he
would go and get him and
he hit him in like 10 000 [ __ ]
folders and we started snooping
shout out to dads out there i don't know
how you just do it god love you it's on
the phone now you don't need to keep
anything
just a tough racket holy [ __ ] this is
from joe we should have talked about
this earlier if we opened up the lunch
me drawer to your fridge what do we see
at my mom's yeah you're going to see
[ __ ] shangri-la
because she does it nice but there's
always some stuff in there that don't
belong there too uh
there's stuff that's maybe it's a i saw
some carrots in there when i was home
what are these doing oh exactly they
were like one of those little tupperware
things it was a couple
that's what i'm saying because like a
baby or something like what's this
yeah nah she does it really really nice
yeah she does it really really good
first of all i don't know who who's
entertaining over there but she now has
the cracker barrel
logs of cheese on the side like they're
in their own little compartment
that's classy you don't think so the
cracker barrel cheese
pre-packaged cheese squares no no no the
the log
the rectangle log yeah that you put out
when companies there yes those are
trashy
no they're not extra sharp kippy dude
that that
that's or you get shitty or you get
cabot curiously sharp fully i got you
dead to rights on this
because it's cracker barrel sharp
yellow it doesn't even say a type of
cheese
look on that packaging it says sharp
yellow yeah they have the white too wise
ass
sharp white it's called we don't know
no they got you'll find that's trashy
cheese though just so you know no it's
not yes it is
cracker barrel what think about what
you're asking me
that's what's what what cracker barrel
is not a nice place
what's what's a first it's not the
[ __ ] that the rest i
assume it is no it's not they're
completely unassociated
they have the same logo it's the same
color it's not the same
i got it we gotta get on to this these
two idiots don't know cheese
it's ridiculous couple of skinny minis
over here
cracker barrel cheese right yeah it's
not associated with it has to
so you're telling me there's just a
popular cheat shitty cheese brand and a
popular
shitty food that's cracker barrel i mean
excuse me
all right i don't know if i'd say
cracker bell is a shitty
organization it has a it has a gift shop
connected to
every single one with facebook like a
bass pro shop with a food shack
they did almost kill my dad with some
expired milk one time
we were eating at the cracker baller
they get a barrel
your dad's ordering milk at the cracker
barrel he's old school what do you think
i get it from
yeah my dad likes a nice glass of milk
toby see if he can pull this up he's the
one that turned me on to milk at
mcdonald's which they make i don't know
where they get it
there's probably so much sugar in that
stuff i could put sugar in milk
what they don't put sugar and i know
sure mcdonald's does no they don't
okay ray kroc wouldn't do that god rest
his soul straight shooter
[Laughter]
handshake deal that's the that's the
trashier cheese depe i got i mean that's
crazy that you're dying
so what what do you got i mean give me
give me a finer rectangular cheese log
hickory farms who's got that much i
don't i don't necessarily wouldn't it
depends i mean a lot of times we'll go
to like the more artisanal thing and
it's like hand wrapped or whatever
sure sure that's on it yeah they're not
doing that also cheese doesn't grow
in that cube like that you know what i
mean like a perfectly square
cube come on i don't know if cheese is
growing or what but i don't come out
like that
you gotta get like the the the misshapen
one the odd formed one i know the little
pizza slice
something like that with a rough edge so
you know you're getting some some good
stuff yeah i know what you're talking
about
um no but you'll find that okay you'll
find those little pre-packed pepperonis
which i know you like ah dude i thought
and she
i could just sit there with a [ __ ]
diet iced tea staying at the [ __ ]
at the island watching the tv with the
[ __ ] remote
dude my biggest treat to myself
is some [ __ ] pre-sliced peppies some
crackers
some sharp vermont cheese and about a
six or
ipas i'll [ __ ] put down the six in
about 300 of them little cracker sammies
i like all that with a sweat
i'll do it i need a little pickle needle
i need a little acid cut through all
that
don't get in the way give me the high
heat okay i retract my statement
because from like hilariously the first
link on google is from the chicago
tribune
chicago uh but yeah no totally different
go [ __ ] yourself it's kraft does cracker
barrel food oh it's craft cheese
yeah and then cracker barrels it's a
boutique operation it's not
in the same conglomerate no no it's like
infinity and toyota
what don't doesn't toyota own infinity
no i think it's the other way around to
be honest with you infinity owns toyota
i think so it's pretty good maybe i
don't know
anyway you'll find that couple of polio
string cheeses you'll find some [ __ ]
you know like an aristocrat you'll find
some lunch meat from corporeally shout
out to court police best tomato pie in
the [ __ ] burbs come on
you'll find some swiss they started
getting in the swiss which we were never
a swiss family
but now they're all about it sounds like
some [ __ ] comedy [ __ ] if you ask
me swiss is great
swiss ain't too shy yeah it's a real
transformer too because it's so
different when it's cold transformers
cheese in disguise
when it's melted it's totally something
changing yeah it's fantastic
wow what's in your fridge we don't have
one now i don't i feel like a fridge
no we don't we don't have a
drawer what am i am i in mine in my new
york apartment
they got to have a crisper you got to
have the button to choose bottom drawers
we have the the the hook on the side
the little guy yeah i don't think we
don't have like two middle drawers
like the two we have the two big ones at
the bottom
[Music]
i think you're gonna need to transfer
the lease
but one of the big things is why because
that's trash you don't have
you don't have the lunch meat drawer i
don't think so weird might be an older
fridge
i don't think it's that old though but
when you go to my mom she's always got
[ __ ] two jaws or two things of pork
roll in there
that's nice we were never that big on
pork roll my brother is huge on it yes
we were scrapple family tree yeah
scrambles
my dad does it so good he made cream
chip beef this weekend the old man still
got
it actually i think my mom made it
all right um this is from jesse ray
wright do you believe in lucky socks or
lucky underwear
this might be a you thing you might
you're a weird guy
i live in superstition yeah so do you
have like a lucky shirt
a lucky anything i don't currently have
a lucky
shirt oh i just got it i just got a
notre dame t-shirt from my dad
that i would say is my lucky shirt it
fits me perfectly and it's
well then it's not lucky you have
sentimental value it's not lucky um
are you ever like i put this on for a
big audition or i wear you know
no you know i guess if you have to think
about it you probably pennies
i have a strict code with pennies and i
never miss one
oh yeah i see a penny on heads my
routine is i pick it up i have to look
at the date
i clean it off a little bit and then i
put it in a pocket that doesn't have
other changes you know
like a homeless person yeah uh big on
that
that's not it's brought you horrible
luck and if i think of something i have
to knock on my
knock on my head i have a whole little
routine do you want to see it like if i
i've seen it like if i say hey you're
going to die
me not so much but if it's do it all the
time don't say that and you knock
yourself if there's
my head can't be touching anything okay
like i can't be laying down
i have to i have to sit up and i go like
this
i have to do that sorry for the audio
listener check it out on youtube
yikes this guy is [ __ ] here i am
trying to have logical conversations
with him i don't
wonder why we end up yelling at him and
if it's something real serious then i
bless myself
i know when i used to go to bed at night
i would have my wishes i would when i
would do my prayers at night i would say
make all my
wish for a six-foot hoagie
i wish for a seven foot hoagie
now you're talking why are you talking
goofballs over here
that's never going to happen what are
your wishes if i tell you they won't
come true jodie
nice try [ __ ] nice try devil boy
yeah there were just a few things that i
you know hope didn't happen
i hope my mom just enjoy home my dad
didn't love you mommy
oh man this guy's so weird yeah man what
do you want from me i'm trash
no you're a [ __ ] wacko sure that's
not trash certain in certain circles
no you're yeah certain arenas you're
nuts oh you're normal
i mean i'm not i learned this i'm not
i'm learning the term ocd
from you i'm not wishing horrible things
don't happen to my family every day
that's nuts
please don't do this please don't do
this like i mean i don't even want to
say it because you're going to spiral
out and
the rest of the podcast won't be funny
so like i can't even give an example
because i know where this ends and it's
not funny down
yeah i got a little bit of that but
lucky underwear
i mean in uh in high school i had a
lucky t-shirt that i always wore
underneath my jersey it was a plain
white t-shirt
that i drew a superman symbol and i wore
it every game my senior year
we won a couple i got in one game
[Laughter]
it wasn't foolproof but you know what i
mean all right this is two
um this is from ryan do you know anyone
who's been married at town hall instead
of actually
having an actual wedding i'm looking at
him right now
i got married at city hall ah yes you
did city hall
in new york is a little bit different
it's not
like you know i'm not going to [ __ ]
you know doyle's town pennsylvania and
getting married at the city hall next to
someone paying a parking ticket you know
what i mean like
i'm at a [ __ ] proper
and good luck with the divorce
you did a city hall in new york yeah so
the witness for your wedding was a guy
in a suit that doesn't fit going to drug
court
you know so they have a huge wing it's
nice
i'm telling you it's i don't know what
you want it's a huge day it's like a
hall
it's a bench it's a hallway no
it's a big big place and uh
it was a scene man it's a [ __ ]
scene down there everybody's marrying
every it's like it's the most
new york thing it's so cool there's it's
interracial enters
everybody's just making out having a
good time we had like 40 people there
foley wasn't invited
green card weddings as far as the icons
yeah
yeah yeah yeah so um uh what's your
voice first name i don't know
who are you again um
yeah it's trashy it's not the classiest
thing it ain't the classiest thing
but you did it nice we had yeah we had
to do it i saw pictures
yeah every wedding in city hall in new
york is in two languages
[Laughter]
yeah i don't even want to do it i want
to tell a story about it that's so
insanely funny but
i mean i we can't yeah got to protect
the innocent here sometimes
yeah yeah yeah um and then this was also
uh this is from tom have you ever me
damn hey have you ever gone into a photo
booth at a wedding
i have like the boa and the funny hat
and the goggles
it's trash it's trash my cousin jordan
had
something similar it wasn't a booth it's
like a green not a green screen but like
a
backdrop yeah it was actually really
classy they had the ring light and all
that stuff
it was nice stretchy trashy i thought it
was nice
the booth is trashy they're all trashy
you're dressing up at a wedding no one's
there to put on [ __ ] goofy glasses
i was at a wedding at a dunk tank once
yeah it was your parents
no a dunk tank do you ever see like
people get mascots they'll get like
swoop from the eagles to come or like
the philly fanatic to show up at their
wedding
man i i think i've mentioned this maybe
on this podcast with definitely hard
feelings
my aunt mike one of my great aunts had a
mummer show up
until like her 80th birthday party and
it wasn't like a big party it was like a
saturday
afternoon we were somewhere on like
henry avenue
in philly where my tests were my that's
where all of my dad's side of that
so one of those backyards you know what
i'm talking about like monte carlo
yeah i grew up in them and [ __ ] all
of a sudden around the corner came this
[ __ ] like 60 year old [ __ ] booze
bag
dressed like [ __ ] spray painted shoes
yeah dressed like elton john
[ __ ] at dodger stadium and i was just
like noop
get the [ __ ] away from me yeah we had
one there was so the venue that we had
our
uh we're not reception did you do the
entrance
because i always thought that was kind
of trashy no offense to anybody but i
always thought
the the the the the what's it called the
bridal party yeah they come in and the
guy dances and the girl dances there's
too many videos of like some guy with
too many in them
like you know hurting somebody yeah like
grabbing her and like throwing them
through his life everybody comes in and
does a funny dance move
everybody's gonna come in and we're
gonna do you're gonna hike me the ball
then you run for a pass and i'll throw
it to you hand me a gun
that's dumb [ __ ] that's like [ __ ] from
the office yeah that's why i don't like
jim and pam
it's corny yeah no bueno but we we
didn't do that no but we did have
there was one at the venue we had like a
private room at a restaurant and there
was one there so it was great for the
kids the kids loved it kids loved it
yeah kids loved it yeah little kids
it can be done nice um yeah all right
let's do one or two more and then
wrap it up there we go what a fun time a
hat one
i don't think you're not a gambler but
have you ever sat at a slot machine with
no intention of playing but only for the
free drinks
i've sat at a slot machine i'll go i'll
do the slots
if i got a little bit of cash on me i'll
do the slots
you know that's my speed okay i don't
know how to play cards or keno or
roulette or whatever it is
remember when you were playing that one
time we were down we were doing stuff
losing my [ __ ] shirt
yeah remember how the the lady was
giving me [ __ ] because i didn't tip the
tip the lady who brought us the drink
watered down drink by the way
[ __ ] paying for that yeah dude you
think this guy plays a cool wait till
you go to a casino and there's rules
he's got to follow he's not a dude he's
looking at everybody like
like it's a sting operation that the
[ __ ] hammers are i always think
they're going to wrestle who's that guy
is this okay if i stand here
where can i not look don't look at the
dealer in the eye treat them like a
german ship i don't like it
yeah i don't i don't like being in a
casino this i'm on some shrooms or
something like that
i got a little picture you should be on
shrooms all the time because you are
high
strung got to mellow this guy out this
kid needs a decaf in a hot meal
ah [ __ ] all right let's wrap it up here
buddy what a fun time
what a fun episode toby thank you t-bar
uh
kippy i gotta tell you really came
through gang grab a [ __ ] pack at ease
okay
go to the website big cartel no it's uh
are you garbage.bigcartel.com the link
will be in the description
shake it off yeah they're fantastic you
guys wanted them we love you
um is that it we got enough yeah yeah
just make sure you
subscribe on itunes if you haven't
already you know youtube you can
subscribe there even if you listen
the audio version just go drop us a
[ __ ] sub you know what i mean it
helps the numbers the algorithm that
whole thing makes us look good shout out
to everybody on patreon shout out to
everybody in the facebook group
we love all you and we'll see you next
week
hold on a second there gang before you
check out
wait one second we gotta talk about the
old stereo app
kippy and uncle hank are on there every
thursday night live at nine o'clock
taking your questions
yeah guys so listen tune in it is a good
time i'm telling you we wouldn't steer
you wrong we got a couple of hundo
people in there too it's fun it's a
party so get in get in early you can
record your question
we'll play it live on the stream then me
and foley chop it up i'm telling you i
wouldn't steer you wrong it's a good
time get involved
check it out peace